the 74th annual primetime emmy
nominations are in honoring the very
best in television with the ceremony set
to take place on september 12th
that's right so let's get into some of
the most buzzed about nominees including
zendaya who made an emmy history again
landing her second nom for her leading
role on euphoria becoming the youngest
two-time acting nominees and they have
previously made emmy's history in 2020
becoming the youngest ever to win for
lead actress
yes and then dance score not one but
three noms this year also earning
recognition in the outstanding original
music and lyrics category meanwhile ted
lasso matched its record breaking
nominations from 2021 by scoring another
20 this year including outstanding
comedy series also making headlines is
dave chappelle's controversial netflix
special the closer which landed a nom
for outstanding variety special
and for some of the biggest snubs i am
not okay with this one yellowstone
[Music]
we will not see the dutton family grace
the red carpet as they were left out of
the race once again can we have a chat
about this i know what is going on and
notably selena gomez was not recognized
for a leading role and only murders in
the building while her co-star steve
martin and martin short were nominated
as well as the show itself
i'm just going to pause right there we
need to talk about
yellowstone we need to talk about selena
how do you not nominate yellowstone like
just
what is the reason i don't get it i we
need to ask that question because i am
addicted to that show
so many people are i even made a tick
tock about it come on but selena gomez
got a nomination makes a tick talk about
it
this is big no it is and i mean
rip was on
you know the tongue of every like that's
what i mean but like everyone was
everyone was talking about
all the time yeah and so
the the way the show was shot the
scenery the cinematography the editing
the acting storytelling like
nothing like not a one and selena gomez
yeah how do you not and you nominate
both of her coasts like
i think that's i think that's dead on
cheryl the fact that he didn't mention
the you know they they both got it but
she didn't i mean it's the trio all
three of them should go to nomination
they work together as a team and that's
what makes them so so funny she's the
addition to that exactly
exactly absolutely okay meanwhile flight
attendant kaylee cuoco received her
second nom for lead actress in a comedy
series and she shared a really sweet
reaction on instagram alongside her
boyfriend and now fellow nominee ozark
star tom hellfreak
the marvelous mrs mazen
okay quinta brunson abbott elementary
kelly coco yes the flight attendant baby
the great
pizza
insecure
being smart hacks
i love that i know i know okay um i'm
just some of the comments here
yellowstone is so good so a lot of
people are not happy about the
yellowstone part of it there's a few uh
the comments are just like
uh
oh let's see yellowstone's a great show
yeah so a lot of people agree with us
yeah no but i love kaylie's um
reaction there it's so genuine and so
cute and a nice behind-the-scenes moment
to see that's fantastic